[Music]
on this sunday night criticism over
kabul
the federal liberals respond to calls
for canada to do more to rescue
canadians and their allies from
afghanistan we know that the conditions
are dangerous and the images we are
seeing are heartbreaking here comes
hungary
the tropical storm soaks the
northeastern united states now carving a
path towards canada
remembering jack the ndp pays tribute 10
years since the passing of a political
giant
[Music]
plus kovitt 19 and the campaign a look
behind the scenes covering an election
in a pandemic
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin again tonight with the dire
situation in afghanistan government
ministers held a press conference to
address concerns about canadians and
afghans desperate to escape the taliban
controlled country the defense minister
says the government and armed forces are
working tirelessly and promised canadian
rescue flights will continue in his
words as long as it is safe to do so
the security situation around the
airport is making it increasingly
difficult for people to get there
the area around the airport is intensely
crowded and violence in the area is
increasing
canada airlifted another 121 people from
afghanistan yesterday including canadian
citizens their families and afghan
nationals so far 12 canadian flights
have evacuated more than eleven hundred
people including one family who arrived
just in time to welcome their newest
member
some thousand afghans have arrived on
canadian soil including a baby girl born
this weekend they'll be starting a new
life here
but many other canadians remain caught
in kabul while some allies such as the
u.s and france are sending buses with
special forces to drive their citizens
to the airport canadians are being told
to make their own way through the
chaotic crowds outside the gates
mercedes stephenson is traveling with
justin trudeau's campaign and has been
following developments mercedes
liberal leader justin trudeau is
swinging east hoping to win over
atlantic canada but he's not been able
to leave behind the issue that keeps
dogging his campaign canada's response
to the crisis in afghanistan today
trudeau defended his government's
handling of the situation i don't want
to go into details
operational details right now but i can
assure you we have given the
authorizations for the folks on the
ground to make the right decisions to
help as many people as possible given
the risks of the situation
nobody was able to recognize them marouf
is an afghan interpreter who worked with
the canadian special operations forces
we are concealing his identity for his
safety he and his wife and five children
ages eight and younger were called to
the airport two days ago by the canadian
government the canadian government is
telling people to wear red and yell
canada to get through the gates marouf
says he yelled for nearly 36 hours in
the crowded and dangerous perimeter of
the airport with no success on that day
we spend all
all night over there the children
the old women
the women's all they were mixed up and
to rush and crowd and it was like a
doomsday marouf is afraid for his life
and wants to know why canada has not
taken the same actions as its allies
sending special forces marouf's former
colleagues who were at the airport out
to collect evacuees
what was happening
together canada is my favorite country
and i have worked with them
and i know their honesty their ability
what was the reason that
that you were so
far away from the the management defense
minister harjit sajin hinted there may
be more latitude there's a reason why we
have sent
our special forces on the ground because
they have the training the ability to
take opportunities despite criticism
from interpreters on the ground the
government insisted they are performing
well pleased to report that we've now
evacuated
a little bit more than a thousand which
is nothing short of miraculous the
liberals have faced intense criticism of
their response to afghanistan too slow
too little too late
and while the liberal leader continues
to make his way across canada there's no
sign he'll be able to leave this issue
behind mercedes stephenson global news
mira machine
and outside that airport in kabul at
least seven more afghan civilians died
today in a panicked crush trying to flee
the country the u.s national security
adviser meanwhile is again warning the
taliban to let every american leave or
face consequences jennifer johnson
reports
heavily armed taliban soldiers have set
up checkpoints around kabul searching
cars and questioning afghans cracking
down to ensure law and order calm down
calm down outside kabul's airport there
is no order afghans are suffering bone
crushing injuries and deaths as
thousands crowd together begging to
leave the country
hundreds are also suffering from
dehydration we've seen these wrenching
scenes of people crowded at the gates of
people hurt
people killed it's an incredibly
volatile situation
u.s officials insist they are moving
troops outside the airport to keep
people from being crushed to death and
getting as many people out as fast as
they can we have sufficient forces on
the ground but every single day the
president asks his military commanders
including those at the airport whether
they need additional resources for
afghans who aided the u.s and its allies
there is overwhelming concern for family
members still in the country including
this woman who was afraid to be
identified they are endangered because i
was working with many
organizations maybe if they are not
finding me they attacked my family one
woman was so desperate to escape her
homeland she gave birth on a military
aircraft moments after it landed in
germany those arriving in the u.s are
receiving aid from groups of afghan
americans trying to help the refugees
rebuild their lives most of them were
very depressed they had so many people
left behind u.s president joe biden held
an unusual sunday press conference after
ordering private airline companies to
fly refugees out of u.s air bases
outside of afghanistan at these sites
where they're landing
we are conducting thorough
scrutiny security screening anyone
arriving in the united states will have
undergone a background check biden is
still facing worldwide criticism for
announcing he's pulling u.s troops out
of the country by the end of the month
even from former british prime minister
tony blair an ally it's tragic what's
happened i think it's unnecessary i
think we made a serious mistake in doing
this in this way leaders of the g7 meet
next week strategizing on how to prevent
afghanistan from becoming a terrorist
breeding ground and protecting those
left behind
jennifer johnson global news washington
turning now to the federal election
campaign and the conservatives unveiled
a bold plan to help those with drug
addictions aaron o'toole spent the
morning at a drug recovery center in
bc's lower mainland abigail beeman has
more on our tools planned to tackle the
opioid crisis
chris esnard was in a very difficult and
dark place a few years ago we used
cocaine yeah a lot of it too you know it
wasn't it wasn't a small amount it took
two stints and years at this recovery
center to help change eznard's life now
his children speak to him again i'm i'm
the happiest in my life i've ever been i
feel fulfilled um you know i i don't i
don't hurt anybody i don't cause any
problems i'm not breaking the law
my kids want to talk to me you know my
my wife she's my friend you know we can
talk again you know we can parent our
kids together
i didn't have those opportunities before
i don't think someone with an addiction
should be punished
i think they should be helped
with a plan much more left leaning
conservative leaders past aaron o'toole
is promising more centers like this one
325 million dollars for 1 000 new beds
and 50 recovery centers a billion
dollars for indigenous mental health and
addictions and free access to naloxone
kits across the country
and he said he wouldn't shut down safe
injection sites
first of all the announcement is
fantastic so far out of all the federal
parties the conservative party is the
first one to actually talk about
recovery and wellness along with
consumption sites but o'toole wasn't
clear on support for decriminalization
of small amounts of harder drugs the
city of vancouver is currently working
on a plan for that we'd like to see more
judicial discretion here to get
treatment options for people with an
addiction and not have them
held back in their recovery and future
employment by by a criminal sanction and
i have a lot of faith that the court
can balance off those factors and while
the promises may sound a little more
orange than blue the ndp and some harm
reduction advocates say it doesn't go
far enough we believe that the approach
needs to be to declaring a public health
emergency to taking on big pharma really
what you have to look at is people are
dying from toxic drugs
and they need access to safer regulated
drugs conservatives head back to ottawa
now wrapping their first week on the
campaign trail with several
announcements like this one aiming to
target more progressive voters and early
polling shows it may be working with the
gap between conservatives and liberals
shrinking jeff
abigail beeman in richmond bc tonight
thanks abigail
the ndp leader jugmeet singh spent today
in toronto paying tribute to a man who
made history before his life was cut
short today marks 10 years since jack
layton passed away from cancer just
months after he led what became known as
the orange crush winning 103 seats in
the 2011 election and becoming the
country's official opposition to
commemorate his legacy singh wants to
see leighton's home riding renamed in
his honor michael couture explains
when jack layton died 10 years ago chalk
messages of condolences filled the walls
of toronto's nathan phillips square
so it was fitting on the anniversary of
the former ndp leaders passing the
current leader came here to add his own
tribute
we are going to carry the torch for you
so we are going to keep on fighting for
that vision that jack had of a better
canada of a better world layton
propelled the ndp to historic heights in
2011 during the orange wave the party
won 103 seats making the ndp the
official opposition
singh has invoked the late leader's
memory many times in the first week of
the campaign and he went even further
sunday announcing after the election he
will introduce a bill in the house of
commons to rename leighton's former
riding from toronto danforth to danforth
layton in memory of jack a move some
believe could be politically
opportunistic in the middle of an
election campaign it's appropriate in an
important time you know 10 years later i
wanted to contribute something to
remember jack to remember his legacy to
remember what he's done and it's not
without precedent we've seen this for
other
notable members of parliament or notable
political leaders that writings have
been named in their honor there are a
number of writings named after historic
political figures including justin
trudeau's riding in montreal which is
named after joseph papineau who was a
political figure in the 1700s
jack layton's son mike is a city
councilor in toronto he sees the
renaming as an honor not political while
he didn't live in that riding he worked
for that riding and for the people that
writing for a lot of years
and
it's it's certainly a lovely gesture to
be made to the family into jack's legacy
noticeably missing from the event was
leighton's widow and former ndp mp
olivia chao party officials tell us she
wanted to spend the morning alone but
chao will be attending a virtual concert
this evening celebrating leighton's
legacy
jeff
michael couture traveling with the ndp
in toronto thanks mike
and mike will be back a little later
with a look behind the scenes of
covering the campaign in the pandemic
plus a storm surge warning in several
states as angry roars ashore
welcome back the u.s east coast is being
battered by tropical storm already the
weather system was downgraded from a
hurricane shortly before making landfall
near westerly rhode island but the storm
is still packing a punch with gusts of
up to 113 kilometers an hour and
relentless rain as ross lord explains
already is not the only extreme weather
event hitting north america
considering it made landfall as a
tropical storm instead of a hurricane
omri is still having a troubling impact
in parts of new england and in new york
state i'm asking you rhode island to
stay home until this storm passes
this is not the time to go out
and see the waves or explore down trees
this is the time to stay home
and stay safe
the problem is that as already weakened
it also started moving more slowly on
its indirect path toward the maritimes
it's very troubling it has slowed down
and as a result considerable amounts of
very heavy rain storm surge along the
long island
new york connecticut rhode island and
southern massachusetts coast retired
meteorologist jim abraham who is also a
climate change researcher notes
hurricanes have become a smaller part of
the extreme weather equation the
atmosphere now
is 1.2 degrees warmer than
pre-industrial age
that's able to hold more moisture but
it's also
unable to provide more heat so we end up
with heat extremes drought extremes or
precipitation extremes this year's long
series of devastating weather extremes
keeps getting longer saturday's
torrential rainfall in tennessee dumped
almost 400 millimeters in some
communities leaving people trapped in
their homes with no way to get out at
least 10 people are dead and dozens more
are missing there's houses moved off
their foundation cars and trees i mean
this is uh this is almost the biblical
proportions here sometimes it's the
unnamed storms that do the most damage
as for already forecasters say the
maritimes will feel some wind and rain
but no major impacts when what's left of
the storm blows through in the next day
or two
ross lord global news
to haiti now where rescue teams are
still searching for survivors from last
weekend's devastating earthquake
mexican rescuers have now arrived in the
country to help sift through that debris
more than 2 000 people were killed in
the magnitude 7.2 quake and more than
300 people are still missing
ahead mong wan joe's extradition hearing
wraps up the ruling and the consequences
for canadians behind bars in china
the extradition hearing of chinese
telecom executive mungwon joe finally
concluded this past week in vancouver
nearly three years since her arrest it
marks a major step closer to a
conclusion for the high profile case
which could carry consequences far
beyond the courthouse
left the vancouver courthouse for what
could be one of the final times
the huawei executive's extradition
hearing wrapped up wednesday nearly
three years since her arrest rocked
canada china relations with beijing
detaining two canadians and sentencing
another to death
their fates as well as monks may now
rest in the hands of the bc judge the
chinese government has been cleared if
mrs mung is not returned to china there
will be no progress hmong was arrested
at the request of the united states and
accused of lying to hsbc back in 2013
about huawei's business dealings in iran
in violation of u.s sanctions
hmong's lawyers argued she never misled
the bank and the fraud charges are
purely political hmong won joe is a
political pawn she's been caught in the
middle of this u.s china trade fight and
that this case is about trade it's about
geopolitics it's about leverage but it's
not about justice hsbc suffered no
actual financial loss as a result but
the crown argued hmong put the british
bank at risk
this is unusual because the u.s has put
so much obviously so much effort into a
allegation of fraud that occurred
outside the united states not by an
american and not necessarily with an
american victim at times during the
hearing the judge sounded similarly
skeptical of the charges at one point
even asking the prosecution isn't it
unusual that one would see a fraud case
with no actual harm many years later and
one in which the alleged victim a large
institution appears to have numerous
people within the institution who had
all the facts that are now said to have
been misrepresented
well the questions that she asked her
and the comments that she made seem to
to
indicate that she's not impressed by the
strength of the evidence but impressed
or not the bar for extradition in canada
is low over the past decade canada has
only rejected about one percent of u.s
extradition requests
well it's of course much much lower than
a criminal trial it is to show that you
have the right person and there's enough
of a case there to warrant the surrender
the judge will set a date for her ruling
in october but the final decision will
then fall to canada's justice minister
if mung loses she's expected to appeal
that could see the case drag on for
years with canadians caught in the
middle
and you can hear much more on this and
other stories on my new podcast china
rising it explores the growing political
tensions between china canada and its
allies from pandemic disinformation to
hostage diplomacy subscribe for free now
wherever you get your podcasts
still ahead jugmeat sings pandemic
playbook a look inside the ndp campaign
amid covet
this election campaign is swapping
shaking hands and kissing babies with
elbow bumps and virtual town halls the
pandemic is changing how leaders get
their message in front of canadians
global news is going behind the scenes
with party leaders to see how they're
conducting the campaign in a time of
covid our michael couture is on the road
with jug meet singh's ndp and here's his
reporter's notebook from the campaign
trail
what a difference two years makes on day
one of the campaign jug meat singh
hopped on his chartered plane to
crisscross the country
compare that to 2019 it took nearly two
weeks for the ndp leader to leave his
bus tour of the greater toronto area
but while he's getting to more places
he can't necessarily get as close to
people because of the pandemic
19 has forced all leaders to adapt
the hugs and handshakes have been
replaced with elbow bumps and waves
it's a challenge for politicians like
singh who thrive in close quarters i
would love to be in big crowds and enjoy
that energy so we're going to have to do
things differently but we'll adapt oh my
goodness
and clearly adapting takes a bit of time
especially when singh's first event of
the campaign was marching in the
montreal pride parade where personal
space was at a premium it's forcing all
parties to conduct hybrid campaigns i
hereby declare his nomination meeting
which would have seen a huge rally in
his burnaby riding was instead virtual
from a vancouver hotel
stop lying to canadians jagmeet public
events do have some pitfalls as the ndp
learned the hard way in toronto hi
and singh still tries to get out and
connect with voters pounding the
pavement with his candidate looking for
votes
there has been one large crowd that was
in edmonton and singh clearly craves
more of it flower on the hands
despite the limits of pressing the flesh
singh is rolling forward hoping to flip
ridings that went to the conservatives
and liberals in 2019
[Music]
some party sources estimate they could
gain up to 12 new seats while others are
even more ambitious believing double
that number of writings are well within
reach
a far cry from the 2019 campaign when
the goal was to limit the damage and
limit the number of seats they knew they
were going to lose
mike liquiter global news toronto
here's a virtual tv elbow bump that is
global national for this sunday night
i'm jeff semple tonight's your canada is
mrs saggy river near sault ste marie
ontario thanks for watching donna
friesen we'll be back here with you
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you